ah bon soir jérôme pineau merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors à
trois ex dirigeants devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris en mars 2022 on
imagine une bonne nouvelle pour vous et
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la de la
justice dans ce dossier
bakel la rendre cette justice parce
qu'il ya quand même des années qu'on
qu'on s'évertue à expliquer aux gens aux
médias aux chercheurs à tous tant
qu'agent libre évident que qu'ils
agissent que que le délit vos agi comme
des truands c'était là le salariat
déguisé c'est du pénal donc là ils
seront au pénal ils vont être accusé de
choses voilà dans nous on les accuse
depuis des années donc c'est un petit
peu une
vérification une certification va dire
de la justice pour l'ascension qu'accusé
ils ne sont pas ils sont pas encore
coupable mais compte tenu des des pièces
qu'on sait être en possession de la
justice puisque déjà on avait les nôtres
plus la justice qui a encore gratté plus
loin que nous voilà ça va être compliqué
pour des livres ou de se sortir de ça
racontez-nous jérôme impie mots quelles
étaient les conditions de travail à
l'époque où vous vous y étiez quel genre
de contrat vous aviez racontez nous
c'était c'était un contrat qui se
voulait un contrat commercial sauf qu'il
y avait tout un tas de choses qu'on
comptait faire on devait en dv porter ce
qu'ils appelaient le branding c'est à
dire les vestes de laissac - typiquement
des niveaux il m'avait viré à l'époque
parce que je ne portais pas le brandy
que je ne portais pas les best bombasse
j'avais j'avais laissé couler je n'avais
pas attaqué en justice moi
personnellement j'étais pas les
prud'hommes parce que j'étais pas autant
se faire là j'avais plutôt décidé les
attaquer dans les médias dans la de
faire en sorte que les livreurs e
attaque et puis c'était c'était les
conditions de travail qui était qui
était très très subordonnant tôt c'était
s'était risqué de travailler pour notre
plate forme même si ça nous est pas
foncièrement interdit mais c'était aussi
une des choses qui m'avait été reproché
c'était en gros on avait supputer que je
bossais pour une autre plateforme
et puis c'était une des raisons qui
faisait que j'avais été viré j'avais
aussi arrêté de travailler pendant deux
mois parce que j'avais eu un accident ça
leur avait pas plu c'était aussi une des
raisons qu'ils avaient évoqué et puis
c'est surtout que mon cas était être
évité a parmi tant d'autres en fait est
ce que vous vous estimez plusieurs
livreurs n'ont pas parlé de ces
conditions de travail avant justement
par peur des conséquences
qui aurait pu arriver
oui oui de ses plateformes savent
entretenir un espèce de psychose en fait
la moindre les premières manifs composer
avec le collectif des livreurs qu'on a
créé on est et on était masqué les
livreurs étaient masquées pour pas se
reconnaître et maintenant encore yens
7,6 cause parce que c'est plate forme
même encore maintenant elles sont besoin
de quasi aucun argument pour virer les
gens vous avez vous allez vous avez pas
livré dans les temps vous avez partagé
votre compte vous avez volé des
commandes fin bref elles ont besoin
d'arguments qui sont indéfendables
puisque souvent les livreurs n'ont pas
accès à une espèce de
réponse ils peuvent pas argumenté donc
évidemment que ça ça fait peur ça fait
peur aux livres de le contredire les
plateformes mais bon plus ça a été a
plus on a fait montrer que dans les
médias la parole médiatique avait quand
même valeur et les médias nous écouter
et à chaque fois qu'on disait quelque
chose souvent c'est même en deçà de la
grille alors vous vous disiez tout à
l'heure que vous aviez dénoncé dans un
premier temps les pratiques sur vienne
via les médias aujourd'hui vous le
faites devant la justice qu'est ce que
vous savez aujourd'hui
des livreurs qui travaillent encore
actuellement est ce que vous pensez vous
espérer que les choses ont déjà changé
sur le terrain
les choses vont certainement changer à
l'horizon déjà changé sur le terrain des
livres ou a vachement changer ces
pratiques ont déplu obligés de
s'inscrire sur sur des créneaux horaires
la justice leur a intimé faut le
politique leur a intimé l'ordre de
supprimer ces fameux créneau rire sur
lequel il fallait s'inscrire c'était ça
aussi hyper contraignant y avait pas de
la place pour tout le monde y avait des
sélections donc ça ils ont été obligés
de les supprimer mais bon ils ont
supprimé des choses mais ils ont inventé
d'autres c'est à dire que maintenant on
est payé de moins en moins il faut
rouler le plus en plus vite de plus en
plus loin c'est d'autant plus de risques
donc voilà si on n'y a si on a perdu des
contraintes on n'a malheureusement une
autre donc sans un sempiternel mans il
faut sans arrêt les attaquer merci
beaucoup jérôme pineau d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes ex l'erreur donc et
cofondateur du collectif des livreurs
autonome de paris merci beaucoup